now really before we go there is there's
one thing I've got to get to I got an
email yesterday from factcheck.org
asking me if I had spread fake news
seriously because you know we have our
thumbnails every day on YouTube and
there's kind of crazy designs we have an
artist who draws them up every single
day and they're always really wild one
of them recently apparently went around
the internet is fake news and it was an
image of a ridiculously defaced Abraham
Lincoln Memorial and it's like part of
his head was chopped off and there's
spray pain that I didn't think it looked
real but apparently some people sent it
around and said this is being two-faced
this is fake news so get this email from
factcheck.org which is a left-leaning
in institution like so many institutions
said were you spreading fake news are
you guys responsible for this and yes of
course artists drew up this thumbnail as
they draw up thumbnails every single day
so just to give you a little bit of
context though I want to go through a
few of the other thumbnails we've drawn
up and just sways your fears and let you
know that those are not real either so
what else do we have in recent days
we've got we've got the Lincoln one
we've got the Statue of Liberty kneeling
on top of a bunch of protesters taking a
knee so I want you to know that actually
the copper statue given to us hundreds
of years ago by France did not suddenly
come to life and does not now have
bendable knees and things like that that
is an artistic fictional image we've got
President Trump as Hercules with a
ripped ripped Greek god body wrestling a
bull by the horns with the face of the
Twitter logo that didn't really happen
okay that's not really Donald Trump and
and the Twitter logo is not a bull then
we've got to Karen's
there Karen's with the Karen haircut you
know and a little dog and a mask
standing staring at you that's not a
photograph that was drawn up by an
artist we've got dr. fowey shaking hands
with Satan himself you can see his
pulsating red devil hands there
dr. pouchy at least to my knowledge has
never literally shaken hands with the
devil
I've metaphorically I don't know I can't
speak to that but literally has not
shaken
with the devil President Trump
dancing around as money falls from the
sky this very possibly did literally
happen but I'm telling you that that
image at least was drawn by one of our
artists oh yeah this one's my favorite a
president Trump dancing at a beach
shirtless we ought to talk to my artist
there's a lot of shirtless Trump in in
these images maybe there's some Freudian
thing I don't know
shirtless ripped pecs you know six pack
abs in a bathing suit dancing in front
of the protesters at the beach who are
saying stay inside and wash your hands
this is not Donald Trump's body everyone
knows that is my body that we
photoshopped president Trump's head on
too so don't confuse that with fake news
yes Bernie Sanders wearing a fur coat
holding up a skull like Hamlet with a
hammer and sickle emblazoned on the
skull that is not the skull of Karl Marx
Vladimir Lenin Bernie Sanders is not the
Prince of Denmark though I often hear
him talk about how Denmark is a
socialist country that also it's not a
socialist country and Bernie Sanders is
not Hamlet this one could be real and I
think a lot of people want it to be real
but it's not real Donald Trump in a WWE
ring body-slamming a very sad-looking
mit romney that did not happen in the
physical world
it did happen politically symbolically
metaphorically but it did not happen in
the physical world and so that is not a
photograph I hope this clears up fake
news I don't want to be accused of
spreading any more fake news by
factcheck.org so keep that in mind when
you talk about the photos of dr. FATA
shaking hands with the devil or
president Trump literally body slamming
Mitt Romney those are artistic creations
I hope you've enjoyed the thumbnails and
I hope that we haven't confused anybody
any further
[Music]
you
[Music]